- All right, so this
show always finishes up
with something cool
trending on social media.
And today's no different, everybody.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
All hour, we've celebrated
love, life, and relationships
with the cast of "The Best
Man: The Final Chapters."
Well, when you've dated
someone for more than a decade,
the question comes up a lot.
"When are you gonna tie the knot?"
One South Carolina bride
wanted to make sure
she heard her friends and
family loud and clear.
After 15 years with her man,
this is how she started her
vows on her wedding day.
(wedding attendees laughing)
(audience cheering and applauding)
(Kelly laughing)
She's literally my favorite
human on planet Earth.
You can see everybody loved
it in not only our audience,
but there at the wedding
as well. It was hilarious.
And we have these newlyweds
on the line right now
watching on WYFF News 4.
What's up, Christie? What's up, Byron?
(audience cheering)
- Hey, Kelly.
- Hey. First of all, girl, you are funny.
That was the funniest thing
I've ever seen at a wedding.
And secondly, Byron,
congrats to both of you.
Like, it looks like that
moment caught you off guard,
and your face was hysterical, man.
- Thank you. Thank you.
It did definitely catch me off guard.
When she was handed her vows,
I looked down and I was like,
these vows just don't look right.
And then she blew the dust
and I was like, what is that?
(Kelly and Christie laugh)
And it took me a second.
I was like, okay, okay,
you got me on this one.
But I think that that
culminated in a good moment
and a very special moment
and we're just happy
to be married for sure.
(audience applauding)
- It's literally my favorite thing
I've ever seen at a wedding.
So, Christie, you say it wasn't just about
being funny, though, right, in the moment?
- Right, I was very emotional
leading up to the wedding
so I knew that if I didn't
do something to break the ice
and kind of at least make myself chuckle,
that I was gonna cry throughout my vows.
So when I did it
and everybody burst into
laughter, I was shocked.
But it actually really worked.
And after everybody calmed
down from the laughing,
I made my way through the vows
and everything that we've
been praying for and wanting
came to fruition and we were married,
and the day was perfect
and it was beautiful.
We just kind of find
ourselves wanting to relive it
over and over again.
- Oh my gosh. Well, thank y'all so much.
Thank you Christie and Byron
for sharing that with us.
I wish you a lifetime of happiness
and you've already had pretty much
a good life already
together, which is awesome.
I'm liking your post right now.
(bell dings)
But that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate your love
and how it stood the test of time already.
So they're gonna give you
$1000, how's that sound?
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Oh my gosh. Thank you so much.
- Absolutely. All because of some dust.
That was hilarious.
Well, thank you guys so much.
And by the way, in case
everybody out there,
in case you're wondering how you can get
your own "Kelly Clarkson
Show" holiday sweater,
'cause I know you are, they look good.
The band looks good.
Just use the QR code on your screen
or go to KellyClarksonShow.com
and click shop.
And if you use the code Kellyholiday,
you'll get 10% off through December 24th.
So Merry Christmas.
Thank you so much to all
our guests this hour.
Morris Chestnut, my co-host.
(audience cheering)
Taye Diggs, Nia Long, Regina
Hall, Melissa DeSousa.
Nicole, Jayla, Anastasia, Ginger,
and Lawrence Zarian, my friend.
From my home to yours, y'all,
have a great day and if it's
not, well, try and change it.
(upbeat music)